candace owens has been watching all of
this she understands that symbols do
matter she's the host of candace she
joins us tonight with a reaction to
all of this chicago candace thanks so
much for coming on is really
kind of a a case study in what happens
when you apply bad policy
that's absolutely right and lori
lightfoot i mean she's a disaster and i
think first and foremost people take a
glance at her and the first thing you
think is this is a woman who is an
avowed racist
and you might look at that and say well
that's obvious because she says she
doesn't want to speak
to any white reporters and only black
reporters but i think actually
lori lightfoot is abundantly racist
towards black americans right so she
pretends oh wait doesn't know what she's
saying pay attention to what she's doing
she's pretending that she represents
black people when she gets in front and
says i only want to speak to black
journalists but that's meant to be a
distraction
actually look at her track record who is
it that she's have her policies led to
the mass homicide of
black people black people are dying on
the streets of chicago black people are
the people that are suffering one you
know in the first quarter
of this year 34 homicide rate increase
it's black on black crime and she has
seen this through
the more important thing though when you
showed a clip of her earlier and she
started talking about
we need help we need help do you recall
tucker a few months ago when i said to
you
that the entire defund the police
movement the entire purpose behind the
democrats do they don't do anything with
that purpose
they are always taking a part and parcel
of a machiavellian scheme
i said to you tucker that they are going
to start requesting on the streets to
get bad enough until they say
we now need federal help and at that
moment you're going to see them start
talking about a federal
police they're going to want to see
federal policing happening on the
grounds of these inner cities
i believe that has been the long game
the democrats have been playing this is
why they have been undermining the local
police
at every second because they are looking
to give more power to the federal
government
this is what is happening in biden's
america and i believe that this is just
really what we're seeing is just a
faster
a faster spread toward america shifting
towards
a federalized police system in this
country
i think that's really smart i i hate to
believe and i remember when you said
that i remember thinking boy i hope
that's not true because it's just it's
just so
it's just so awful um that you would
create
chaos you allow hundreds thousands of
people to die just so you become
more powerful but i think i think you're
absolutely right
so in other words they did none of this
was accidental i mean they knew
defunding the police would get a lot of
people killed how could you not know
that
of course they knew that and you look
around you have to study history and
that's why i've said you see them
they're calling themselves socialists
they're hitting the ground
they're demanding socialism well let's
actually take a look at what socialism
has been around the year
social has been around the world pardon
socialism has led to the death of 100
million people all across the world when
you look at communist
socialist regimes of the past this is
what you see the federal the federal
government needs more and more power and
they need to make sure they take it away
from local yes they are taking this away
from local so the democrats put this
plan into place
and now it's speeding up so she's she's
not helpless she's saying we need help
from the federal government we help the
federal government so that
eventually people on the streets are
going to say please anybody help us
and you're going to start to see real
crimes from the federal government when
they put their boots on the ground and
start saying okay
now we have complete and utter control
it is not chaos from chaos
dictatorship arises that is the lesson
of human history
it's amazing you make you i'm i'm
completely sold and
chris ray we're getting to expand the
fbi by
you know 3x so they can keep order in
chicago
uncle tucker i need office time every
day every day
tell me that 14 more times and i'll
believe you with some exclamation points
dennis owens great to see you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else